heyget seven and today I'm going to open
my mail with you guys I had a whole
bunch of mail accumulate over the
holidays and it's going to check it and
I win then I basically have a backpack
full of mail and saw some cool packages
in there and so I wanted to open it up
with you guys today and you can join me
the adventure let's see what I got I
usually don't like getting a lot of mail
because most of my classes online by the
avoid me as much as possible my address
is not on my website anywhere and yet
people still find me with stuff so we'll
see what we got here what is intriguing
was these packages so I have three
packages that I saw here that I want to
open up
so usually wall crappy stuff don't care
don't care bills invoices you know you
guys all love this stuff whoo that might
be a check we'll see that's always good
checks make me happy sometimes they go
out with different Christmas cards most
of those already came in
here's a Christmas card from a happy
worker
I think it's Christmas card hockey
workers a fun company they make custom
toys for people
certified wedding my name's Chris they
always have some fun stuff so let's see
what it says a little bit it with you
guys let's see it says happiness monster
versus joy bot the ultimate battle of
bliss and you open it up
do your evident crew and hate in this my
son big half of 2013 wishes this is a
fun game wishing you joyful holidays and
happy ever ever happy
everydays from the team and happy worker
and it looks like there's some kind of
game here that have to play can you guys
see this I'm the joy bot but I can't
come to life all by myself need to
create me and together will bring joy to
everyone except one think joyful
thoughts up to remember the fun of
crafting when you are young lighter
laughs and three ticks pair of scissors
cut careful along the parts or cut
anywhere if you feel if you're feeling
extra creative except for assemble and
glue or tape the parts on into one joy
and filled robot step five together with
the Dre but make and share joy and you
can get this at happy worker comm slash
holidays slash joy bot you can read that
ok that might be interesting to try and
we'll see what happens I think my son
might enjoy that stuff let's ditch all
the kind of traditional mail for now
open that later and see what's behind
[Applause]
door number one
which one should I go with this one so I
got a DHL Express package again it says
clothing on the outside so we will see
it says DHL we packed I don't know what
that means I think maybe somebody opened
it up and then had to pack it up again
oh you know what this is from mr. Nam so
let me tell you the story mr. na is one
of my readers on my newsletter when we
find an email
he's from Ethiopia and he loves all of
my newsletters that are coming in and
wrote in the say I want to send you eat
the old video Ethiopian tradition of
where as a Christmas gift would you send
me your instructions sign of your cat's
trouser body skeleton as well as your
height weight and your address I know my
chest size and I'm using about a 40 and
trouser but I know in the body skeleton
right so I kind of gave him the
information that I could and he sent me
this so this is cool I'm gonna go try
this on and then we'll see how it goes
okay so here I am in my traditional
Ethiopian dress where I'm from from miss
canal and let me back up here so you can
see so it's it's interesting it's
actually super comfortable here is
really loose
I'm here oh there's pockets too I don't
know what these symbols mean I don't
know what that that it's it's an
interesting design but I don't know what
that symbol means hopefully means
something positive it is middle winter
and I'm from Canada so I can't wear this
anywhere anytime soon
I decide at least for this is super
comfortable and this cannot sentiment
because of all the advice all the help
that I've given over the time with my
newsletters so cool thank you so much
we'll see what happens on this car this
is interesting I've never received a
traditional Ethiopian gift so thank you
miss kana let's open up the next ones
here we got another package here I bet
you never would have thought today you
guys watching I'm new to round up this
video and man here he is in traditional
feel including this one is from the UK
biodegradable clothing oh okay this is
from Rob I think so rob has a company
called raccoon meat Rapanui I believe I
forget we'll look it up I'm sure it's in
here he's got this t-shirt company that
has organic biodegradable t-shirts and
he had a cool shirt that was talking
about the purpose living a life on
purpose as I wrote to him and he said he
would send me a shirt so thinking this
is it ha
[Applause]
we got one here this is soft wow this is
great
so it says can you read it here purpose
hashtag purpose is the new status this
is super soft
alright to try this on and you also sent
a hoodie oh and a candy cane
but can't you take that from up here the
hood okay I'm gonna try this stuff on
and I'll be back okay so here I am with
my my rapanui clothing 9 this is some of
the most comfortable stuff I've ever put
on this is amazing I don't know what
it's made of
it says here has an equal label so has
an eco rating of a and a means it's the
best that you can be so a is a super
super good for the economy the
environment and gee I guess is is the
worst that you get they're the worst
so you're shopping consciously but I
don't know what it's made it but it's
super comfortable I feel like I uh I
feel like I need to jobless and I want
to go to sleep this is great the hoodie
too is also really nice I love it for a
couple reasons I love the message here
purpose is a new status maybe I'll use
these in some of my videos and the
hoodie is great too if I zip it up here
you'll see it's also long I like a
little bit of a longer enough it's a
little too high yeah but it fits so you
wrote a message here Rach hi Evan this
time thanks to you support hope your
shirt on her D and hoodie fits okay's
happy face so to learn more about this
company its twitter.com slash Rapanui
clothing on facebook.com slash trapper
annoyed clothing but you got the sizing
down this is great okay
last package do we got this one feels
like a book now a lot of offices sent me
their books and I've just kind of run
out of reading times and some almost
stopped accepting books from authors so
let's see which one I accept here's this
is great okay so this is by a guy named
Taylor branch and Taylor branch is is an
author and this book won the feel of
surprise or Taylor branch at least when
it do the surprise it on Facebook but
I've been really focused this past
couple months on nearly building a
movement that's why I really love this
shirt purpose you're building a movement
you're doing something that's important
doing something that has purpose that's
your new status and I was really
interested in Martin Luther King and how
he started his movement the Equal Rights
Movement and his role in it and most of
the stuff that I saw was was huge thick
books and what I loved about this one
was it gave a quick overview of all the
historic moments that happened during
the civil rights movement so I saw this
book and I wrote to the author Taylor
branch tonight and I asked him on
Twitter if you would send me a copy
because I wanted to read it and then
share it with you guys as well and he
responded to me on Twitter so I wrote in
and he wrote back to me to say thank you
tell me your mailing address and I'll
send you a signed copy myself
so this is the book I'm excited let's
hope you sign it Taylor did you sign it
I asked her signed copy
yes there you go so you wrote here at
the top to Evan Carmichael or for Evan
Carmichael with best wishes Taylor
branch December 23 2013
so Thank You Taylor I got some reading
material I'm gonna go
through this and as I find something I
want to share I'm going to highlight it
to share with you guys those are the
interesting packages that I got so thank
you for my Ethiopian clothes a thank you
for mine about the newly clothing here
and thank you for Taylor
sending me this book I'm excited to read
it candy cane is a nice bonus for my
canoeing
I saw got the other email of the other
messages sorry we'll go through that see
what have to do with those bills and
everything else thank you guys for
watching enjoy give it a thumbs up below
I know you guys still want to see what's
in my fridge a lot of you wrote in
saying what's in your fridge today is
not the day you can see what's in my
fridge it's gonna come soon
I'll keep you posted then why don't you
think thanks guys juice